joining me on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line is the general manager of the
las vegas raiders who's
getting ready to take on the baltimore
ravens on monday night football in their
beautiful new stadium with fans in it
for the first time mike mayok back here
in the rich housing show how are you
michael rich i only caught the end of
that but is
is it true that you were responsible for
getting watts signed to the steelers
well
he there may be other moving parts he's
taking credit
maybe other moving parts but what i'm
saying is i counseled here from this
position that their position that they
sh don't
do business a certain way they should
make an exception for somebody like watt
and if anybody comes around and says
yeah you did it for tj you just simply
say yeah you're not tj
and it looks like they did that so
that's my only conclusion i could make
is that they heard me
mike i think they probably did rich
thank you mike you know you know
i'm just look for affirmation that's all
you know that's what i walk around
looking for affirmation from right but i
am i am curious how a deal like that
lands in a lap of another general
manager uh in the in the nfl and what
you think of that now that
clearly a bar has been raised in a way
uh for others what do you make of that
deal mike you know i'm always intrigued
rich by how other teams do business
because they're really 32 separate
footprints
everybody does a little bit different we
all have different thoughts about how
far to carry guarantees out
um
i'm less intrigued by the numbers even
though
they're big numbers and more just
intrigued that they were flexible enough
to change a policy they had which is
kind of what you highlighted
um
and i'm always trying to figure out
which way this league's going which you
know and
what what what
i think agents look at it just like we
do
what's becoming more and more acceptable
where are the guarantees going where the
percentage is going so i'm just always
intrigued by these deals to kind of
learn the details about how ultimately
the deal got done but does that is that
the way sometimes things go where an
agent calls up and says you did
something for somebody else and you're
going yeah well i like your guy but uh
he's not the guy that you're referring
to right does that the way it works mike
you know i mean i think in any industry
when precedents are set certain people
are going to want to use that precedent
to their advantage
then it's your it's your job to
basically press your case as well on the
other side you've got to push back i
imagine you'll have to take the human
being into account right so what is on
your
table on your inbox now now that we're
ready to play football what is what what
is your job what is your gig entail
right now
mike well i'm i'm kind of anxious to get
on the road a little bit rich and you
know me i i like smelling the grass yes
and you know once you get through final
cuts and you make some adjustments to
that 53 etc and you're you're heading
into the roster i think
what i learned when i was at nfl network
was that all 32 gm's kind of had their
own way of doing business during the
season
uh ozzie newsome a guy who i loved
you know ozzy believed in being in the
building
365 days a year know your team better
than anybody else's team um kevin culver
an awesome general manager always loved
being out in the road and he felt like
he had to see the players personally
and you know everybody's got their own
reason for doing things i like to get
out there and see it so i'm going to get
out to a game tomorrow
next week when we go to pittsburgh on
the way there i'll get a chance to see
another game i'll get to some practice
so basically as the season progresses
what i try to do is balance being in the
building with john
and staying on top of our roster with
getting out there and seeing some of my
area scouts and seeing some of the
players in each area what game are you
going to tomorrow who are you seeing
i'm going to see texas a m at colorado
oh okay
i love it
and then you just go there and so you do
you have guys that you're thinking of
who you're already in mind like how do
you approach something like that before
you do that before you then obviously
head home for for your game on monday
yeah i'll look at our scouts reports
which will take me in the right
direction of who the guys to watch are
during the game
and i probably did four or five hours of
work on guys
you know this week
that are in that game so at least i'd
have a preview of what they look like a
year ago
and then i'll be down on the field
pregame kind of getting the body types
and my notes pregame and then there'll
be a few guys that i'll focus on with
the binoculars from the press box what
do you think of the realignment going on
right with oklahoma texas going to the
sec how do you think this is
this constant shifting there's now a
historic alliance between three
conferences how do you think that's
going to affect talent evaluation or the
the caliber of players that are going to
come to the next level mike do you think
anything on this front or what i i don't
think i'm smart enough to think anything
about that right now okay um
my brain cells are limited and i know
okay i kind of have to be heared a
certain way and you know rich there's a
lot of there's seminal change right now
in in college sports in general right
you know from paying the players to
to the realignments and i think the rich
get richer and the number of conferences
get smaller and
um you know i think they're an awful lot
of different ways to look at both those
issues and and again i think it's just
going to shake out over time mike mayak
here las vegas general manager uh right
here on the rich eisen show raiders and
ravens on monday night football coming
up so what uh how has gus bradley's
arrival uh helped shape your roster in a
way and some of the moves that we've
been seeing over the last couple of days
and weeks and months as well mike
well
first of all um
gus embraces communication both amongst
his coaches
the players and me
and you know he walked in the door and
we've got a pretty good feel for what he
prefers
by position body types what they look
like how they move what they look like
what they smell like you know he's very
specific and that helps us
evaluate players
the communication skills that he
displays and the leadership skills
i think are top level
um and i think
any time you get a guy like that at any
position in your building it's helpful
so he's been great to work with on a
bunch of different levels
and i think the players have
uh responded to his approach
um and the goal you know on monday night
is
to play fast and and and keep it simple
so how different will it look i mean
what can you tell
your fans who are hoping that the
raiders defense shows up in a manner
that is
uh a little bit more stout and something
you've even referred to uh needing
improvement how do you think that's
going to look what can you tell we
weren't very good last year and and we
obviously need to get better and i think
any time you're talking about getting
better in the nfl it's a combination of
of talent and coaching and there's no
real ratio it's just you need better
players
and uh you need to coach them up and so
we we made a concerted effort to get
better on defense
both in free agency and the draft
i think gus has done a great job of
galvanizing that group of men
and to be really honest i mean we've got
some guys that have done it individually
at the nfl level level
but
i'm really anxious to watch how we play
collectively
against one of the benchmark teams in
this league the baltimore ravens how big
a year is this for abram mike walk me
through this this kid who you had such
uh great regard for using one of your
multiple first round picks on a couple
years ago and he's been banged up how
big is this a year for him and his
evaluation and his career
it's a big year for him it's a big year
for a lot of our guys but i mean for
john specifically
he i think he's got to show two things
number one that he can stay healthy and
number two that he can play at a high
level consistently and those are his two
challenges
okay and then how's the general health
of your team going into the season
uh knock on wood we feel pretty good um
every team in the league is dealing with
issues right now and you know all we can
control is what we can control okay and
how is uh jacobs is he healthy
is he ready to roll
oh i think he'll be fine i mean josh is
just one of the toughest kids on our
team and
um we just think the sky's the limit for
josh jacobs what's the challenge for the
uh for this team against the ravens on
monday night the match up the x's and
o's here that you're looking forward to
playing out on monday night here for you
i i don't know
i mean on offense
obviously rich i think a storyline for
us it's less
raven intensive and more
you know how we're going to look up
front with our revamped offensive line
you know how are our wide receivers
going to respond our young wide outs
and on defense uh can we affect the
quarterback you know and and if you're
talking about the ravens
can we stop the run i mean they've had
an awful lot of injuries
uh recently at the running back position
specifically but number eight still
available so
uh when number eight's on the field
there's a big play waiting to happen how
are you enjoying being a gm mike
i mean i know it's been a couple years
now how you uh you you like it you enjoy
it this is what you envisioned
everything well i'm enjoying it a lot
more this year now that i'm more like a
gm than i was last year when i was a
cobit manager
um but if if we don't win more games i'm
probably going to be back there sitting
next to you
well i you know uh first of all uh i'm
not big on the elephant in the room you
know reggie i know
well there there is that elephant you
know and and um that's kind of why i'm
like asking if you're enjoying it
because there's so much talk about you
and gruden and the decisions and the
making of the roster and some of the
decisions that were recently made is
there anything you want to address on
that front since we're the elephant is
sitting right there
mike yeah i'm 63 and i'm and i'm pretty
pragmatic and i knew what i was getting
into i've been a football person my
whole life and at the end of the day
you either win enough games or you don't
and i think we're getting for me
and i think we're getting to a critical
juncture we got to win some games and it
starts with monday night football
against the baltimore ravens right here
uh on westwood one and uh mike i yeah i
don't know if you saw we uh we opened
the new uh studio for nfl network you
wouldn't believe it
if you know i know you're gonna have a
game and so far you should just come
next door and just take a look for a
minute it's unbelievable
i've heard that uh we played the rams
pre-season and oh people were kind of
buzzing about it because you were almost
done construction at that point right
it's incredible mike you would honestly
you would not believe it and a lot of it
is due to some
considerable hard work by all the people
that you've known for a very long time
um and it includes you so you should you
should please stop by and and check it
out you know it really is it's been a
long time since you nailed aaron rodgers
dropping all the way down to 24th
overall when we were talking about nfl
total access in 04 to today it's cr it's
crazy you would i would i would imagine
that it's probably not going to reduce
the amount of time you spend talking
about quarterbacks regardless of the
digs well you know mike i i will tell
you this uh hold on a second hold on a
second
uh the rich eisen show got into the name
image and likeness business with uh a
partner gorilla glue and we're giving
name image and likeness deals to guys in
the trenches
and people who make tackles and we're
not we're we're
and if it's a quarterback it's going to
be somebody that at a school that's not
expecting the the money and the
attention because that's what we do here
we're punching
your partner's always about giving back
mike you take care of yourself we'll
chat again soon okay appreciate the time
yeah it's mike mayok the general manager
of the las vegas raiders
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here